Добрий ранок бігі вітається із Едді
своєю вантажівкою вона належить компанії
але тільки біг дозволено керувати нею
брджет мош заступає на зміну усього і
побільше
сюди наступні пть днів бігі їздитиме
їстиме і спатиме на скромних 5п
квадметрах салону
вантажівкимені простоце подобається це Я
не можу описати мені просто тут дуже
добре Вона за кермом уже 30 років
сьогодні перші 50 кмт бігі проїде без
причепа дорогою до свого першого вантажу
вона виявляє що під'їздна дорога
заблокована
чорт
забирай доведеться їхати іншою
дорогою
Чи я зможу пройти А я
пройду чи не
пройду тісно але бігі знає свого
Едді проблему вирішено час для наступної
о вони вже розвантажуються я не можу
під'їхати до свого трейлера трейлер біг
ліворуч а інший стоїть праворуч проїхати
ніяк
я мушу розвернутися і заїхати задом
через
склад проїхати заднім ходом через склад
повний перешкод - це дуже тонка робота
повільне і точне маневрування щоб
з'єднатися із причепом сьогоднішній
вантаж спеціальна Промислова
[оплески]
фарба О Боже
мій
нічим не гірше за
спортзал Настав час випити кави поки
Вода закипає бігі займається
формальностями тут написано 7:00 А ми
були тут раніше 7мої щойно ми закінчили
під'єднуватися вона зберігає все для
свого роботодавця на бортовому
комп'ютері Катерина боймле молодша
менеджерка компанії знаходиться у
головному офісі бортовий комп'ютер
вантажівки дозволяє Їй завжди точно
знати де і коли знаходяться бігі та
Едді тут ви бачите що Минулого понеділка
був дуже щільний трафік вона могла
проїхати всього 4 км за 50 хвилин тому
сильно запізнилася коли ми бачимо це то
можемо реагувати і вирішувати що робити
далі тобто тут ви можете стежити за всім
так
для компанії перевізника важливо все
відстежувати зрештою у них 160
вантажівок на рейсах але їм не вистачає
водіїв катеріна разом з батьками
переглядає нові заявки на роботу молодша
менеджерка сподівається найняти більше
жінок-водійок взаєми не складаються
по-різному наприклад у конфліктних
ситуаціях які Сподіваюся будуть
рідкісними у мене були жінки які
вибачалися на наступний день тому що
вони були не в настрої таке буває але не
з чоловіками тож це інша форма взаємин
та обидві статі можуть виконувати свою
роботу однаково
добре тим не менш лише троє зі 180
водіїв жінки бос вважає що це занадто
мало нам загалом потрібно більше
людей тому ми раді кожній людині яка
приєднується до нас кому це подобається
хто бачить цю роботу як покликання
і неважливо яка їхня стать
50кіметрів уже позаду і кавабрейк біги
закінчився їй та Едді час знову вирушати
в дорогу у цю справу треба вкладати душу
і серце інакше нічого не вийде Я кермую
вантажівками не тому що мушу а тому що
хочу Візьміть наприклад Едді мою
вантажівку Звісно це вантажівка але він
також мій напарник ми разом коли йому
погано мені теж погано Так само як і в
партнерстві Я одружена на своїй
вантажівці якби у мене був партнер який
сказав би мені що я маю покинути цю
справу Я б сказала Ні я не піду Іди геть
водіння - Це моє
життя любов бігі до водіння коштувала їй
двох шлюбів Це її не турбує але вона
глибоко шкодує що більше не бачить своїх
двох доньок Я ніколи не була поруч із
ними лише по телефо
ніру зараз жінка приїхала ближче до
своїх доньок вона не хоче прогавити ще й
можливість бачитися із онуками Та це не
означає що вона збирається покинути свою
улюблену роботу поки що бігі та Едді
будуть і далі долати кілометри
[музика]
доріг